>> THANKS, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: SEAN HANNITY TAKES
OVER RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: THANK YOU, GREAT
SHOW, WELCOME TO >> Sean: ANY
SIX.
AS AMERICA'S RADICAL NEW
GREEN DEAL DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS
FOR THEIR MARXISM SOCIALISM, THE
PEOPLE FROM CUBA WHO HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING END OF THIS FOR
DECADES, EVERYBODY WILL SHARE IN
THE WEALTH, NEVER WORKED OUT FOR
DECADES, THEY ARE NOT RISKING
THEIR LIVES IN SEARCH OF
FREEDOM, SOMETHING WE PROBABLY
ALL TAKE FOR GRANTED.
IT'S NO SECRET UNDER CASTRO'S
MURDERING MARXIST REGIME, THE
CUBAN PEOPLE HAVE LONG FACED
DIRE SHORTAGES OF FOOD AND OTHER
BASIC SUPPLIES, EVEN TOOTHPASTE,
MEDICINE, SOAP.
THERE'S A REASON THEY'RE STILL
DRIVING CARS FROM THE 1950s,
BARELY HELD TOGETHER BY LIKE
STRING AND SUPERGLUE.
EVERYTHING FROM ENERGY TO EGGS,
IT'S ALL RATIONED.
EVERY CUBAN CITIZEN IS ONLY
ALLOWED FIVE EGGS A MONTH,
THAT'S IT.
NEEDLESS TO SAY, THE QUALITY OF
LIFE IN CUBA OUTSIDE OF THE
RULING ELITE, THEY DO GREAT.
IT IS ABYSMAL AND DURING THE
ONGOING UNPRECEDENTED NATIONWIDE
PROTESTS IN CUBA, DEMONSTRATORS,
THEY ARE NOT CALLING FOR MORE
EGGS OR MORE RICE.
INSTEAD THEY ARE CHANTING
"FREEDOM" AND "DOWN WITH
COMMUNISM."
THEY ARE CARRYING CUBAN AND THEY
ARE CARRYING AMERICAN FLAGS.
YEP.
THE SAME AMERICAN FLAGS THAT WE
WATCHED ON THE FOURTH OF JULY
AND WE SEE A LOT.
WE SAW IT LAST SUMMER.
MANY LEFTISTS IN AMERICA TRASH.
YEAH, THOSE AMERICAN FLAGS.
EVEN IN THE FACE OF A MASSIVE
GOVERNMENT CRACKDOWN WITH MASS
ARRESTS NUMBER RISKING LIVES,
CUBANS CONTINUE TO TAKE TO THE
STREETS, RISKING THEIR LIVES
EVERY MINUTE IN THE PROCESS.
MANY LIKELY WILL BE MURDERED AS
A RESULT OF THESE BRAVE EFFORTS
THAT THEY ARE INVOLVED IN.
BACK HERE AT HOME IN THE U.S.,
OH, AMERICA'S TOP RADICAL
SOCIALIST, THEY ARE, WELL,
PREDICTABLY YET EERILY SILENT.
LIFELONG COMMUNIST, THE GUY THAT
HONEYMOONED IN THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION, BOLSHEVIK
BERNIE SANDERS, PRAISED CASTRO'S
LITERACY PROGRAMS AND FREQUENTLY
ATTACKED REPUBLICANS, HE'S BEEN
COMPLETELY SILENT ABOUT THE
ONGOING DEMONSTRATIONS IN CUBA.
SO, SENATOR, DO YOU STAND WITH
THE PEOPLE OF CUBA FOR LIBERTY,
FOR FREEDOM?
CONGRESSWOMAN OCASIO-CORTEZ, THE
REAL SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
MISSING IN ACTION.
THE LEFT SOCIAL JUSTICE
WARRIORS, THEY TOO ARE MISSING
IN ACTION EVEN STILL TONIGHT.
ONE TIME BACKUP QUARTERBACK
TURNED WOKE PROFITEER
COLIN KAEPERNICK.
SEE HIM DECKED OUT IN HIS BED
ALL CASTRO SHIRT, HE DOESN'T
SEEM TO CARE ABOUT THOSE WHO ARE
CRYING OUT, RISKING THEIR LIVES
FOR FREEDOM IN COMMUNIST CUBA.
COLLIN, BY THE WAY, THE GUY ON
THE SHIRT THAT YOU'RE WEARING IN
THAT PICTURE RIGHT THERE, THAT
GUY?
YEAH, HE WAS NO RUTHLESS MASS
MURDERER.
MAYBE THAT IS SOMETHING TO TAKE
IN THE ABOUT A MONTH MAYBE SOME
SOLIDARITY FOR CUBA'S FREEDOM
MOVEMENT THAT'S GOING ON.
SO FAR IT'S CRICKETS.
ONE "NEW YORK TIMES" COLUMNIST
PLAYING "SHOUTING "FREEDOM" AND
OTHER ANTIGOVERNMENT SLOGANS."
FREEDOM AND OTHER ANTIGOVERNMENT
SLOGANS.
POORLY WORDED, DO YOU THINK?
THOUSANDS OF CUBANS TOOK TO THE
STREETS.
OTHER ANTI- -- I CAN'T GET OVER
THAT.
FREEDOM AND OTHER ANTIGOVERNMENT
SLOGANS.
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES" -- I
GUESS FREEDOM IS AN
ANTIGOVERNMENT SLOGAN.
THAT SHOWS YOU HOW FAR THEY'VE
SUNK IN THE SEWER.
THIS IS A CALL FOR HUMAN RIGHTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE TALK ABOUT
RIGHTS -- WE BELIEVE IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE ARE ENDOWED BY GOD,
THE CREATOR OF EVERYTHING
NATURAL, GOD-GIVEN RIGHTS, NOT
GOVERNMENT RIGHTS IN THE FACE OF
A TYRANNICAL COMMUNIST
DICTATORSHIP, A MURDEROUS
DICTATORSHIP.
IT'S NOT JUST SOME GENERAL
ANTIGOVERNMENT STANCE THAT'S
GOING ON IN CUBA.
MEANWHILE TODAY, JOE BIDEN
FRANKLY HAD TO BE SHAMED AND
BARELY MUSTERED THE COURAGE TO
GIVE A SHORT STATEMENT TO MANAGE
THE FREEDOM FROM THIS MURDEROUS
REGIME.
ONE BIDEN STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL ACTUALLY LYING, BLAMING
THE PROTEST ON COVID-19.
"PEACEFUL PROTEST ARE GROWING IN
CUBA AS THE CUBAN PEOPLE
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO PEACEFUL
ASSEMBLY TO EXPRESS CONCERN
ABOUT RISING COVID CASES IN
MEDICINE SHORTAGES."
WELL, FIRST OF ALL, LET'S START
WITH THE FACT THAT STATEMENT WAS
AND IS A COMPLETE LIE.
IT IS NO RIGHT TO ASSEMBLY IN
CUBA.
HE WOULD THINK THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF JOE BIDEN
MIGHT KNOW THAT.
THERE ARE NO RIGHTS IN CUBA,
PERIOD, JOE.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO TELL THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK UNDER YOU IF
YOU EVER KNOW WHAT DAY IT IS.
ANY EXPRESSION AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT IN CUBA CAN LAND YOU
IN PRISON AND YOU COULD END UP
DEAD AND NEVER TO BE SEEN OR
HEARD FROM AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT THESE PROTESTS ARE
ABOUT, NOT COVID, NOT SUPPLY
SHORTAGES.
THE CUBAN PEOPLE ARE DEMANDING
FREEDOM OVER TYRANNY.
THEN PRESS SECRETARY JEN PSAKI,
SHE JUST ADVANCES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LIE THAT THE
CUBAN PEOPLE JUST NEED A FEW
MORE VACCINES, THAT WILL DO IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
PROTESTERS ARE JUSTIFIABLY OUT
THERE IN THE STREETS PROTESTING
ABOUT IS HUNGER, LACK OF ACCESS
TO VACCINES, ET CETERA.
WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE AND
UNDERSTAND THAT ACCESS TO
VACCINES IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT A NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
VOICING CONCERN ABOUT BUT WE
HAVE TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
MECHANISM WOULD BE TO WORK WITH
THE CUBAN PEOPLE TO GET VACCINES
TO THEM.
THAT'S SOMETHING WE'RE WORKING
THROUGH.
>> Sean: NO, THEY ACTUALLY
NEED FREEDOM.
AGAIN, ANOTHER LIVE FOR GUTLESS
JOE.
PROTEST IN CUBA ARE SIMPLY ABOUT
SHORTAGES, SOCIALISM, PROMISES
GUARANTEED, FOOD, MEDICINE AND
INCOME.
IF YOU GIVE UP YOUR FREEDOM AND
WHEN AS ALWAYS IT FAILS TO
DELIVER, YOU DON'T GET YOUR
FREEDOM BACK AND THAT'S WHY THE
PROTESTERS ARE CHANTING
"LIBERTY."
SENATOR RUBIO WILL JOIN US IN A
MINUTE AND HE'S ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
AS I HAVE SAID MANY TIMES, YEAH,
I DON'T CARE, SOCIALISM,
COMMUNISM, AUTHORITARIANISM,
WHATEVER HISTORICALLY --
WHATEVER NAME YOU GIVE IT, THEY
PROMISE EVERYTHING.
IT'S ALL GOING TO BE FREE, FREE,
FREE.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
AND THE PROMISES ALWAYS END IN
UNFULFILLED PROMISES OF UTOPIA,
MORE POVERTY, THAT'S GUARANTEED,
AND UNDER MANY REGIMES, DEATH
AND DESTRUCTION, AND THEN YOU
CALCULATE AFTER THE PROMISES
HAVE BROKEN HOW MUCH OF YOUR
PERSONAL FREEDOM DO YOU GIVE UP
IN THE NAME OF WHAT WOULD BE
FALSE SECURITY OF THE GOVERNMENT
AND IN THIS CASE AT THE HANDS OF
AN OPPRESSIVE DICTATORSHI